get on your face right now get out
Punjab oh yeah get on your face my name
is Freddie Joe Farnsworth and the United
States Marines well I've heard that
we've got a couple of young wild
recruits that need to be not something
so I think we should get started little
get up come here
[Music]
I was like as soon as the door opened
they were like come on
[Music]
one of the misconceptions are that our
whole job and our whole life that we're
just people that are out there to be
mean go to countries and run the
countries and so on and so forth but
we're all human beings with big hearts
that trained very hard to stay alive and
to protect our friends that are with
this animals are just like humans
repetition repetition repetition when
they're wrong you have to let them know
the wrong when they're right yet they'll
know that they're right when they're
babies you have to really let them know
how right they are people that have PTSD
TBI they always have a dog
and there's a reason for that it's not
because of this is cute leaves and ugly
is when I'm in combat I can sleep
because I know Jim's awake but when I
leave combat I don't have that anymore
but there's one thing that will always
let me know no matter what somebody's
walking up on me somebody is there is
this and that's why you always see those
guys in this like that's their baby it's
the best thing for pulling military
people all these beautiful puppies are
up for adoption at Vanderpump
[Music]